i have a confession to make
but first
i want you
to make a little confession to me
in the past year wouldn't you just raise
your hand if you've experienced
relatively little stress anyone
how about a moderate amount of stress
who's experienced a lot of stress yeah
me too
but that is not my confession
my confession is this
i'm a health psychologist and my mission
is to help people be happier and
healthier
but i fear
that something i've been teaching for
the last 10 years
is doing more harm than good
and it has to do with stress
for years i've been telling people
stress makes you sick
it increases the risk of everything from
the common cold to cardiovascular
disease
basically i've turned stress into the
enemy
but i've changed my mind about stress
and today
i want to change yours
let me start with the study that made me
rethink my whole approach to stress this
study tracked 30 000 adults in the
united states for eight years and they
started by asking people
how much stress have you experienced in
the last year
they also asked
do you believe that stress is harmful
for your health
and then they use public death records
to find out who died
okay
some bad news first
people who experience a lot of stress in
the previous year had a 43
increased risk of dying
but
that was only true for the people who
also believed that stress is harmful for
your health
people who experienced a lot of stress
but did not view stress as harmful were
no more likely to die in fact they had
the lowest risk of dying of anyone in
the study including people who had
relatively little stress
now the researchers estimated that over
the eight years they were tracking
deaths
182 000 americans died prematurely not
from stress but from the belief that
stress is bad for you
that is over 20 000 deaths a year
now if that estimate is correct that
would make believing stress is bad for
you the 15th largest cause of death in
the united states last year
killing more people than skin cancer hiv
aids and homicide
you can see why the study freaked me out
here i've been spending so much energy
telling people
stress is bad for your health
so this study got me wondering can
changing how you think about stress
make you healthier and here the science
says yes when you change your mind about
stress you can change your body's
response to stress
now to explain how this works i want you
all to pretend that you are participants
in a study designed to stress you out
it's called the social stress test
you come into the laboratory and you're
told you have to give a five-minute
impromptu speech
on your personal weaknesses
to a panel of expert evaluators sitting
right in front of you and to make sure
you feel the pressure there are bright
lights and a camera in your face kind of
like this
and
the evaluators have been trained to give
you discouraging non-verbal feedback
like this
now that you're sufficiently demoralized
time for part two a math test and
unbeknownst to you the experimenter has
been trained to harass you during it
now we're gonna all do this together
it's gonna be fun
for me
okay
i want you all to count backwards from
996 in increments of seven you're going
to do this out loud as fast as you can
starting with 996. go
go faster
faster please you're going too slow
stop stop stop stop that guy made a
mistake we're gonna have to start all
over again
you're not very good at this are you
okay so you get the idea now if you were
actually in this study you'd probably be
a little stressed out your heart might
be pounding you might be breathing
faster maybe breaking out into a sweat
and normally we interpret these physical
changes as anxiety or signs that we
aren't coping very well with the
pressure
but what if you viewed them instead as
signs that your body was energized was
preparing you to meet this challenge
now that is exactly what participants
were told in a study conducted at
harvard university
before they went through the social
stress tests they were taught to rethink
their stress responses helpful
that pounding heart is preparing you for
action
if you're breathing faster it's no
problem it's getting more oxygen to your
brain
and participants who learned to view the
stress response as helpful for their
performance well they were less stressed
out less anxious more confident
but the most fascinating finding to me
was how their physical stress response
changed
now in a typical stress response your
heart rate goes up and your blood
vessels constrict like this
and this is one of the reasons that
chronic stress is sometimes associated
with cardiovascular disease it's not
really healthy to be in this state all
the time
but in the study when participants
viewed their stress response as helpful
their blood vessels stayed relaxed like
this
their heart was still pounding but this
is a much healthier cardiovascular
profile it actually looks a lot like
what happens in moments of joy
and
courage
a lifetime of stressful experiences this
one biological change could be the
difference between a stress-induced
heart attack at age 50 and living well
into your 90s
and this is really what the new science
of stress reveals that how you think
about stress matters
so my goal as a health psychologist has
changed i no longer want to get rid of
your stress i want to make you better at
stress
and we just did a little intervention
if you raised your hand and said you'd
had a lot of stress in the last year we
could have saved your life
because hopefully the next time your
heart is pounding from stress you're
going to remember this talk and you're
going to think to yourself
this is my body helping me rise to this
challenge
and when you view stress in that way
your body believes you
and your stress response becomes
healthier
now i said i have over a decade of
demonizing stress to redeem myself from
so we are going to do one more
intervention
i want to tell you about one of the most
underappreciated aspects of the stress
response and the idea is this
stress makes you social
to understand the side of stress we need
to talk about a hormone oxytocin and i
know
oxytocin has already gotten as much hype
as a hormone can get it even has its own
cute nickname the cuddle hormone because
it's released when you hug someone
but this is a very small part of what
oxytocin is involved in
oxytocin is a neurohormone it fine-tunes
your brain's social instincts
it primes you to do things that
strengthen close relationships
oxytocin makes you crave physical
contact with your friends and family it
enhances your empathy it even makes you
more willing to help and support the
people you care about
some people have even suggested we
should snort oxytocin
to become more compassionate and caring
but here's what most people don't
understand about oxytocin
it's a stress hormone
your pituitary gland pumps this stuff
out as part of the stress response it's
as much a part of your stress response
as the adrenaline that makes your heart
pound
and when oxytocin is released in the
stress response it is motivating you to
seek support your biological stress
response is nudging you to tell someone
how you feel
instead of bottling it up
your stress response wants to make sure
you notice when someone else in your
life is struggling so that you can
support each other
when life is difficult your stress
response wants you to be surrounded by
people who care about you
okay so how is knowing this side of
stress going to make you healthier
well oxytocin doesn't only act on your
brain it also acts on your body
and one of its main roles in your body
is to protect your cardiovascular system
from the effects of stress it's a
natural anti-inflammatory it also helps
your blood vessels stay relaxed during
stress but my favorite effect on the
body is actually on the heart
your heart has receptors for this
hormone
and oxytocin helps heart cells
regenerate and heal from any
stress-induced damage
this stress hormone
strengthens your heart
and the cool thing is is that all of
these physical benefits of oxytocin are
enhanced by social contact and social
support
so when you reach out to others under
stress either to seek support or to help
someone else you release more of this
hormone your stress response becomes
healthier and you actually recover
faster from stress
i find this amazing
that your stress response has a built-in
mechanism
for stress resilience
and that mechanism is human connection
i want to finish by telling you about
one more study and listen up because
this study could also save a life
this study tracked about a thousand
adults in the united states and they
ranged in age from 34 to 93.
and they started the study by asking
how much stress have you experienced in
the last year
they also asked how much time have you
spent helping out friends
neighbors people in your community
and then they use public records for the
next five years to find out who died
okay so the bad news first
for every major stressful life
experience like financial difficulties
or family crisis
that increased the risk of dying by 30
percent
but
and i hope you are expecting a butt by
now
but that wasn't true for everyone
people who spent time caring for others
showed absolutely no stress-related
increase in dying zero
caring created resilience
and so we see once again that the
harmful effects of stress on your health
are not inevitable
how you think
and how you act can transform your
experience of stress
when you choose to view your stress
response as helpful
you create the biology of courage
and when you choose to connect with
others under stress
you can create resilience
now
i wouldn't necessarily ask for more
stressful experiences in my life
but
this science has given me a whole new
appreciation for stress
stress gives us access to our hearts
the compassionate heart
that finds joy and meaning in connecting
with others
and yes your pounding physical heart
working so hard to give you strength and
energy
and when you choose to view stress in
this way
you're not just getting better at stress
you're actually making a pretty profound
statement
you're saying that you can trust
yourself
to handle life's challenges
and
you're remembering that you don't have
to face them alone
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
i mean this is um this is kind of
amazing what you're telling us it's just
it seems amazing to me that a belief
about stress can make so much difference
to
someone's life expectancy
how would that extend to advice like if
someone's making a lifestyle choice
between say a stressful job
and a non-stressful job is it does it
matter that which way they go that it's
it's equally wise to go for the
stressful job so long as you believe
that you can handle it in some sense
yeah and one thing we know for certain
is that chasing meaning is better for
your health than trying to avoid
discomfort and so i would say that's
really the best way to make decisions is
go after what it is that creates meaning
in your life and then trust yourself to
handle the stress that follows
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]